i want to let you guys know i'll be
coming to town with the return of the
rat tour october 11th and 12th
in wichita kansas they still have
tickets for the 11th
at the orpheum theater
october 13th omaha nebraska that's sold
out
and uh october 14th denver colorado
um those shows i believe are sold out
we're gonna add some new omaha and
denver dates
they'll be i think either later this
year in the spring so if you weren't
able to get tickets
we'll put some new ones
up soon for the return of the rat tour
thank you guys for your support you can
get your tickets at theovonn.com
t-o-u-r
we have new be good yourself teas in new
summertime colorways like banana salmon
check those out and more
theovonstore.com
today's guest is hitting the road with
his new make joke from face tour
um he's been here before
he's based uh he was from minnesota he's
that cold baby
and um
he is uh he's been on reno 911
grandma's boy
and he's led a real uh interest in life
of debauchery and hilarity
um i'm excited to have him back my
friend comedian nick swardson
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
all right what's up dude
what up nick
what's up take your [ __ ] wig
look all the effing cops dude what's up
man what's going on dude i haven't had a
drink in two months so i've got that
sober energy is that true yeah i'm
[ __ ] sober kai
wow yeah so you really so two months no
alcohol
no i had one drink for a celebration
but then i just stopped it at that which
is rare but so you had a drink within
the past two months yeah but it was one
so i don't count that
what what what counts to you as drinking
40 drinks in a night wow yeah have you
ever had that
um
i have i remember one time i did i did a
show in miami
and i don't know if you've ever done
this but i had one miami dude well
you've been to miami but i had one show
it was like a college gig
and i [ __ ] stayed for a month
damn i just stayed at a hotel for a
month and my opener patrick key and
super funny and after like two weeks
he's like what what are we doing and i'm
like
miami bro and he goes yeah that's great
i've got to go home like i have like
another job and like a like a life yeah
and i'm like oh yeah right okay and then
i got him a plane ticket home and i
stayed another two weeks just drinking
just drinking just chilling and uh i
remember the hotel bartender
i'm not bragging about this but kind of
the hotel bartender goes um mr swartzen
and i'm like yeah and he goes um
you just drank a whole bottle of gray
goose today
and i go okay and he goes yeah how are
you feeling and i'm like i'm good dude
i'm like another cocktail and he's like
yeah all right i [ __ ] just ripped
miami up dude
great good did you if you drink a whole
bottle like greg who's you you become an
endangered species i think at that point
yeah i think i started to get feathers
on my jenny's [ __ ] yeah this shit's
got real i was waking up in an egg i'd
like come out and [ __ ] it was crazy
you've never done that i've done that
many times where i've done a gig and
it's always [ __ ] florida yeah it's
like when i i told you this when you
told me that yeah yeah i went to key
west for supposed to be ten days during
the pandemic yeah i was a year and a
half
and you ran up i heard that you ran up a
bill at a at the hotel there that was
like astronomical it was insane i stayed
at a resort on the beach for a year and
a half and it cost i heard a million
dollars i don't think it was a million
but it was probably it was a lot of
money if you tipped did you tip i always
tip i'm really good at tipping i think
it's important
what do you think it was when you say a
lot of money how much was it i mean it
was definitely
probably half a mil for sure but it was
i feel like i feel like it was more than
that it might have been i kind of don't
want to know because i just went into
the ether of just
[Music]
and then just listen to live music and
[ __ ] but um but how so
because i remember a time i came and met
you i was in some city you were
performing there i was performing there
and i came and saw you and you were day
drinking at a hotel like
yeah and not like at a pool party it was
like a dog like
it was like kind of like a dimly lit
just like a bar in star wars or
something yeah it was just creatures or
there are people there
i didn't see any bartender i do remember
a hand would come up every now and then
oh no
it would just conjure up a beverage oh
my god
witch magic yeah or like the hand like
from adam's family would just come in
and [ __ ]
dude i heard that hand molested like a
bunch of kids dude stay away from hands
if it's just a hand
it's up to no good
um
but yeah i remember going to meet you at
a you're like yeah come over we're
partying everywhere we're hanging out
and i got there i don't know
and i think it was football season and
it didn't even have any tvs in it and i
was like this is
what really that's weird that was
because i remember being like oh that
because i know you're a vikings fan i
was like that's weird but
and there were like cavernous things lit
there was like light like torches it was
oh my god who was i with frankenstein
what the [ __ ] man what is wrong with me
i felt like is this part like a
geologist thing it had a very indiana
jones meets like um i mean i do a sober
living right okay that's interesting i
do
hunt for treasure when i'm on tour i do
try to find treasures so i do end up in
some sketchy snake spider bars did you
all
so you quit you had to quit drinking
i had to take a timeout yeah but um yeah
i like pick and choose like i've gotten
to the point where like labor day
weekend like holiday weekend i'm gonna
drink okay you know what i mean but then
i i won't go like bonkers because i'm
going on tour this fall starting after
labor day and i remember i'm gonna not
drink as much as i used to because it
got so
i would just get caught up with fans and
going out and then there was one time
couple times there's one time i
sincerely did this i walked out on stage
in louisville kentucky
and this is genuine i walk out and i go
dude not only is this my first time in
louisville this is my first time ever
performing in louisville
and this guy goes
nah you were here last tour and i'm like
yeah i know but not this theater and the
guy goes
yeah it was this theater and i'm like
it's great to be back in louisville good
to see everybody again
but it's because the time before that i
don't drink bourbon and i went out and
people took me just ripping bourbon and
that was just one of those alcohols
where this is the switch yeah it's just
bye oh yeah next you know you're trying
to [ __ ] just suck off your knees yeah
man you're trying to [ __ ] blow your
knees and a possum just starts fisting
you and you're like [ __ ] game on
yeah so i mean and then chicago is one
of my favorites i love chicago
and i went out until six in the morning
on division street and i was in such a
blackout but i do remember like windows
you know like when you remember just
little vignettes oh yeah yeah yeah
little commercials yeah so one of my
little commercials was uh i went to
mcdonald's at six in the morning and uh
i peed my pants
and i was so hammered and i peed and
then i ordered a shitload of food like
way too much on this tray and then i
turned around and slipped to my own pee
and then threw all the food all over the
place i wiped out
panicked and ran out and then
had to find my hotel i just gotten in i
had no idea what was going on and then i
woke up did sound check and my tour
manager was like
what does that smell and i go oh god
yeah i peed myself and he was like what
the [ __ ] it's another bladder dude
that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
nick bladder i can't believe you dude i
saw a guy pee actually in a like this is
insane i remembered this man
this was growing up dude we had like two
i don't know if we had two homeless guys
bus but we had like one gay guy and
everybody like was like that guy's
homeless you know because he didn't have
a wife and kids and he was like
they just
immediately equated him to homeless i
mean it was like you know that was the
times you know it was 1940. i was just
saying
oh look at this homeless guy you know
he's perfectly dressed he's like what
no i just don't like women
nope you're a degenerate homeless person
get off the streets you know he's like i
own this shop right here we sell flowers
whatever homeless
whatever that's hilarious but i remember
uh
this other dude had pee remember they
had those mcdonald's have those trays
you know bring up a mcdonald's tray can
we
you know what i'm talking about i know
what you're talking about it was a tray
yeah the the brown one they used to have
the brown one yeah
yeah that's what i'm talking about yeah
so
this guy had peed and would just get a
perfect like
what balance and he would carry it like
it was a trap because whoever came in
the second you touched it the piss would
come off oh i like that [ __ ] what did i
think of that
um
so but obviously so it sounds like i
mean you've obviously had some issues
with drinking you know yeah i've gone up
and down with it i mean there's no
secret there yeah how bad did it get
like what was one of the times where
you're like damn this is
because it's just a sneaky thing i mean
half our audience i think probably
doesn't you know or struggles with all
kind of [ __ ] yeah for sure i mean it's
interesting i've always tried to find a
balance because i never thought
i was like a raging
alcoholic like when i would drink i
would drink but i never craved it you
know what i mean it wasn't one of those
things where like i'd gone to aaa
meetings and stuff and i would hear
stories like go to an a meeting just to
hear some [ __ ] get real
[ __ ]
i mean there were people that
a would do like 8 10 meetings a day
which is fine this isn't me judging
anybody but like there was there are
people that couldn't walk past a bar
there were people that couldn't even
look at an empty like people tell
stories about being at a wedding and
they couldn't even look at an empty
champagne glass without having like a
full panic attack yeah
so i mean i was never at that point i
would just like get into a you know if i
had time off i'm like well i'm just
going to get drunk
because it's fun as [ __ ]
like there's a there's also a contingent
of people that drink that do enjoy it
like i didn't start fights i wouldn't be
rude there wouldn't be like that when
you meet somebody they get drunk and
i'll send them racists now oh god like
that type of [ __ ] i just always had fun
yeah so that was kind of the catch-22
it's like
being when you're like that you just you
just have fun with it yeah dance and
[ __ ] and fart
yeah that's true man i guess there is i
guess if you're if you're having makes
you have fun it's tough to like you know
curtail it back you know yeah the late
north macdonald was one of my best
friends
he uh he had so many great drinking
jokes but one of them he goes uh
and i'm loosely paraphrasing but he goes
uh yeah yeah yeah
my uncle's an alcoholic and my mom was
like yeah your uncle's he's got a
disease alcoholism it's a disease
and norm goes well as as far as diseases
go that's a that's a pretty good one
it's like hey uncle rick what happened
last night well i went out in that my
disease kicked in
ended up laughing all night and then had
sex with a stranger
i always like
love that take on it
yeah that is a good take man yeah i
think if you can have if i think part of
the alcoholism is that you don't ha you
get so down about whatever you do you
know it's like yeah instead of just
being like oh i had a great time they're
like you know you start like going
through all the things in your head of
like oh this and this and now it makes
me feel you're just too like sensitive
almost you know you have a sensitivity
to
not just the alcohol but to whatever
you of being out of control i think yeah
totally and if you when you get to a
point of like drinking and driving is
[ __ ] horrible like i don't even know
how people get duis done with like uber
and lyft and [ __ ] what's the furthest
you ever drink and drove dude being from
minnesota it's probably i drove to
hawaii
from l.a dude i don't know how i did it
woke up in my car with a [ __ ] bunch
of dolphins i don't know what happened
man
um
the fur i mean nothing like of length i
mean i have friends who have been
blacked out we would do last call in l.a
and they would drive to vegas
after last call so that's just so you
know that's like four hours but that's
drugs too probably
i know this my friends those guys that's
a funny thing though do you have like
friends that casually do cocaine
i have friends that are like nine to
fivers on the weekends they [ __ ] get
all zippy'd
and then and then they're back on monday
they're like what's up jerry yeah how's
the counting or whatever people you know
that have jobs
yeah i think i i think i do probably
know some people like that you know that
always fascinated me are they lying
but also i mean i don't know i can't do
that [ __ ] but
i mean i've done it but whatever
um
yeah that's just insane that you that
you like go to a place and just stay
there it's interesting i know but it's
like fun yeah where it's like i'm not
you know it's just i don't know why not
oh it's cool
a lot of times i feel bad that i have to
leave certain places like i want to get
to know this place a little bit better
this town or see what's going on you
know so when you tour we've both toured
forever
it what and you just you live in
nashville now yeah and i was living in
key west so if you could settle down at
a town you weren't living you stayed at
a hotel yeah but i mean for a year and a
half okay i mean that's a lot that's a
residence oh did you start to like i
knew everybody it got [ __ ] crazy it
was like mayberry on mushrooms dude when
people every day when you go to the to
the to the hotel room next door like hey
i'm nick i'm your neighbor would you say
that yeah
yeah i knew the mailman even though he
didn't bring me mail he would just bring
me coupons and i felt like i was
involved
i knew everybody and wow that was fun as
[ __ ] man that is nice key west yes i
remember one time
i was just in such a good mood
and um i had some cash i mean somebody
owed me money and they drove down from
minnesota to give me money that they
owed me but it was cash it was like 10
grand in cash so then i just was a cash
happy you know what i mean oh so i was
tipping [ __ ] everybody yeah like my
friends that play at the uh at the bars
down there i would request a song
and i'd be like hey play this and they'd
be like no we're not playing country
road by john denver again and i'm like i
know but and i just keep giving him
here's three of those [ __ ] come on
what are we doing take me home country
[ __ ] road man
but i gave there was like some um
like kind of um uh homeless not
teenagers but just younger people kind
of like you know just oh yeah i know
you're talking yeah like kind of
kids or something punk dudes you know
probably in their 20s like what do you
mean like art students or something i
would i would i'll say that
but i don't know but they were just kind
of like they were just chill like they
were beach homeless like they were just
like people like kids that spray like
dude we had this kidding i'm sure
they've drawn something we had this kid
named todd that drank a [ __ ] can of
spray paint dude which is so hard to do
he drank like a cocktail he drank it he
just was like she sprayed it straight
into his [ __ ] throat oh so he um
what's that called like huffing or
something just having i don't know what
they say drank it yeah just having paint
i mean because yeah it wasn't gas only
he got paint
god i know pretty [ __ ] cool that was
back when people didn't give a [ __ ] you
know that's really not giving a [ __ ]
yeah i feel bad for him was at least a
throat color so it didn't
oh he was all he never he would never
really hands him anyway out of the gate
but i think that's part of this thing
he's like i'll just [ __ ] he's like
i'm just gonna paint my
[ __ ] grill
that is awful you see somebody riding
that can bro it [ __ ] makes you hard
bro why would it make you hard because
you know what somebody's going through
when you're [ __ ] right there with
them so how long did you guys date i
never did it it's just that's no contact
homosexuality right that's just admiring
just admiration yeah yeah i think that's
a word yeah
is this guy still with us like out of
respect i'ma stand here and get hard for
you
right that's it's an homage to you izzy
i'm not sure i don't know what happened
to that kid he was always
no he he he took a thing again he did a
hit of gasoline one time he's just
[ __ ]
did he not know about vodka did anybody
tell him like hey what was his name todd
todd t-o-d-d yeah not t-a-h that's a
classic todd move by the way
some names you just affiliate with [ __ ]
like that you're like todd yeah and all
of his teeth didn't kind of fit in his
mouth someone was i don't even know what
he was you know he was so he's like i'm
gonna make him blue um no he just got on
that can baby all right but
i'm saying people have used all kinds of
drugs over the years oh dude there was
one [ __ ] oh wait so the the punk
dudes by the beach
so um they were always like so cool you
know they were like what up nikki
and so one day i'm like just i
got a buzz yeah and i gave him like
four or 500 bucks
i'm like hey guys
you know what go have fun huh go yeah
but i was so dumb i'm gonna get your mom
some sandals yeah want to go buy your
mom some sandals and maybe throw it
throw dad a dream catcher yeah let's
[ __ ] go you guys want some sandies
get some food
no they didn't do that so then the
police that became friends of mine
they uh rolled up my friend dave he's
like nick did you give um some homeless
youth
um a bunch of money and i go yeah man
they're really cool they're really fun i
gave him like yeah a couple hundred
bucks and the guy's like yeah don't do
that anymore and i go wow he goes we
just arrested all of them they just went
on a crazy like bender drug bender and
just ran around naked i think and like
broke into a lighthouse i don't know
what the [ __ ] they did but i got like
reprimanded and i was like right so they
didn't spend it at they didn't give it
to the church
okay
yeah [ __ ] gets rogue dude
well actually i got that tattoo right
there rogue is that say it yeah dude
that literally show your tattoo it looks
like a place where you go and pick out a
font for like a wedding thing or
something like that yeah
i was gonna marry that paint huffer
we gotta get it decided i was gonna get
the lightest black dude
the robot from short circuit this is his
dick
holy [ __ ] man
what's going on
the wait is almost over that's right a
new football season
begins this week
get ready for nfl week one action with
draftkings sportsbook
an official sports betting partner of
the nfl
to celebrate the return of football
draftkings is giving new customers a
can't miss offer
bet just five dollars on any football
game and get two hundred dollars in free
bets instantly that's right
draftkings is safe secure and reliable
best of all you can deposit and withdraw
your cash whenever you want
download the draftking sportsbook app
now and use promo code t-h-e-o to get
200 in free bets instantly
when you place a 5 bet on any football
game that's code theo only at draftking
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details
now a word from our sponsor better help
being well is key
if you look outside of your window if
you look outside of your
house
or car apartment there's people that are
unwell
people running around people eating bird
seed
people doing stuff like that people
spitting water in the air and trying to
shower under it
people are unwell
that's why you have to take care of
yourself and take care of your brain
and better help
they can do it
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
only therapy sessions
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to
there's just so many ways to you get to
to communicate with people
people that can help you
they will put you in touch betterhelp
will put you in touch and get you
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours and it's much more affordable than
in person therapy
take care of your brain stay well get
off the bird seed
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot-com slash
theo
[ __ ] steven segel dude dude flock of
cigals
we were talking about steve we had
dinner with our friend david spade last
night we loved it man what an adorable
lawn gnome that guy is yeah you know
there's just something um
you just want to [ __ ] just
you just want to pick him up and just
throw him into a ceiling fan you know
what i mean just happy and then
yeah
and he's out no we love david and we
were talking about him and david are
developing a movie together yeah we
wrote a movie you wrote a movie but
you're developing it yeah developing it
sounds like we're just thinking about it
and smoking weed
no it doesn't it sounds like you're
developing something really like when
you're developing like a development
like a building you're developing it so
you're not like just sitting there like
the building would look cool there okay
yeah it's in it's coming into fruition
okay all right that's fair thing yeah
because i read the script it's really
funny it's like joe dirt meets dumb and
dumber with you and david
yeah it's good and it's about it's like
a love story
um but it's not an annoying love story
no it's a it's like a buddy story yeah
it's like a buddy story and then he's
trying to get love you know and what do
you think about that process like
writing a script because it's such a
different muscle i've been a writer
since i was 24 i wrote malibu's most
wanted bench warmers grandma's boy and
it's really interesting don't you think
because it's [ __ ] hard as [ __ ] you
really need discipline
and it's hard to like because you get
the thing about is like you get married
to jokes and bits in a movie but you
also need story so you've got it it's a
compromise i'm writing a movie right now
with the director of grandma's boy nick
goosen and it's still hard because you
want to keep funny [ __ ] but you also are
like
this doesn't make any sense
yeah i mean there's like
it's hard first of all it just takes a
lot of time it's like i have to like
settle my brain from like stand up or
from like
aaa or from like um well you have tons
of [ __ ] in your podcast it's you have so
many things right so you and you have to
have enough like energy and creativity
to sit there and work you know just you
just go back and forth you put it in
you're like okay this kind of works this
works and then you get the whole thing
done and you're like okay we have too
many jokes we don't have enough
reason why this guy wants this yeah you
know and you have to have a reason in a
movie you know yeah you've gotta like
because the thing with dumb and dumber
was one of my favorite movies and the
thing that makes it work and i was
telling spade this last night because i
read the script it's really funny but
i'm like you need a little bit of
like motive and heart
a little bit more because dumb and
dumber there's a scene corazon
what corazon what does that mean spanish
heart heart oh heart in spanish i like
that thank you yeah
but there's a scene in dumb and dumber
where jim carrey and jeff daniels are
arguing about
something in the apartment and about
going to find the girl
and jeff daniels goes i'm sick and tired
of blah blah blah blah and jim carrey
goes you know what i'm sick and tired of
what is it he goes i'm sick and tired of
being a nobody i'm sick and tired of
eking my way through life and it's
really sincere and really dead serious
and most of all i'm sick and tired of
having nobody doesn't that guy say that
yeah i'm yeah i think that's it too and
then you just go oh these guys aren't
stupid they're real people then like
they have feelings and like and then you
go with them on that journey because you
root for them right and that's such an
important scene that people don't
realize
makes that movie because when you really
care about them yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah we'll be right back with
more from [ __ ] characters yeah more
from why it top more from white oprah's
um
yeah it's been interesting man and david
has so many jokes so he loves the joke
so he's like we'll get together and
we'll write him like
we'll i'll leave that with like 70 more
jokes in no more story lines yeah that's
the trick dude you got because i've
worked with david a billion times so and
he always wants to joke but you gotta
get the story down and then put the
jokes around ow [ __ ] the robot to check
me but just so you know that's an
insight into screenwriting and comedy
writing insight we didn't [ __ ] tell
these people anything yeah
weaver dude i will [ __ ] do a line and
[ __ ] your cousin dog what are my cousins
have monkey pucks well bring it on dude
yeah didn't you think that was a cereal
when it first came out monkey
a lot of people are calling it zoo aids
a lot of gays are calling it zooey
is that true [ __ ] yeah i'll adopt that
term yeah that's funny zoo aids
oh my god who wants to freaking dude he
wants some [ __ ] zoo aids who wants to
huff in these zoo dude was it
anyway
speaking of zombies go vikings
this is a shirt company minnesota on a
stick because everything goes on a stick
there what did you guys just got uh
do you guys have um herschel walker
no do you guys still have uh
what is that guy who they caught putting
that stuff in his trunk that one time
tara top put stuff in his trunk no brad
what's his name bill's quarterback
brad oh brad johnson yeah yeah no we
don't still have him
no he works at [ __ ] pf chains an hour
or so does he really i think so i have
no idea but i saw rufio at pf chang's
working
it was dark in there
he could have been oh he like literally
popped out of the wall with a freaking
ponzu sauce [ __ ] yeah he did yeah i
remember there was some actor that got
[ __ ] on in the like tmz or something
about having a waiter job in l.a and
everybody would like got really pissed
off because it was like dude are you
shooting on somebody for just grinding
sometimes [ __ ] dries up this guy needs a
job yeah i respect that
um by the way i love pf checks when
you're on the road is there like a go-to
restaurant when you're touring for me if
i can find a pf chance i'm not sponsored
by them yet but let's change that p f
yeah
so i mean you know is there like do you
[ __ ] with cheesecake factory no i don't
do anything like that dude i like to eat
a jimmy john
yep i like jimmy john's i like to have a
nap
and then i
spinach and maybe chicken
okay i keep it pretty same thing every
time almost all right it gets pretty
boring some numbers i don't know we'll
stop at some diners but a lot of the a
lot of diners have changed over the
years they're not the same like you go
in now and it's like a greek diner where
they have like breakfast lunch tire care
yeah you know jean jackets yeah it's
just like yeah like unlimited denim for
dessert and you're like this is insane
they have a [ __ ] velour buffet i
can't digest any of these
they've got they still have crystal
pepsi yeah my clothing has everything
yeah my cousin has two pockets and a
zipper stuck in his throat it's like we
can't even go out as a family you just
get they put they do operations you get
a zipper mouth it's [ __ ] nuts man hey
good morning you know you're too much
man unzipping your kid's face yeah you
get an old wham t-shirt for dessert yeah
it's like they've just everything's like
it's like i don't know it's all like
it's hard to find some of the good mom
and pop places like they used to have
they've all changed a lot of them are
now like a greek and lebanese
which is fine but there's just not just
a breakfast diner it's not like two eggs
and a salsa you know it's like right now
there's like somebody in there playing a
sitar in the corner yeah and there's
like casting spells you don't know
what's going on yeah they're selling
like one of their daughters in the
bathroom issue they're trading her up
for cats yeah you start crying spiders
you're like what the [ __ ] is going on
man dude stop the music
jesus i just wanted a hash brown i just
wanted one hash brown you order a hash
brown and some dude name a black dude
named hash comes out there and you're
like what is everything's just changed
you know yeah it's different man it's
just a different world out yeah i do
like mom and pop that's why i like bars
like that too you know what i mean that
was kind of the annoying thing about the
pandemic was that
all the chain restaurants stayed open
but all like the indie restaurants and
mom and pop places took a hit we should
have bailed them out all the dive bars
and stuff you know it's like that's
what's important i think
[ __ ] if i can rally about bailouts man i
was just seeing that
what do you think about the um
christian bailout christian bailout i
don't know i don't know why that came
into my head oh you mean henry
affordable
um you mean uh
who was the guy that played indiana
jones carson ford
carson ford who was that
harrison ford
yeah harrison ford harrison carson ford
that sounds isn't that like an auto
dealership
i don't know man i don't know you
freaked me out okay yeah i did you you
[ __ ] drank at a bar for a year and a
half in key west you hung out with
people that drank
um spray paint
yeah one kid yeah that's enough i didn't
hang out with him i grew up i drank out
with millions of people none of them
drank spray paint that's just insane
but i mean bless him
it doesn't sound that bad you've had
moonshine right you had to have had
moonshine
i've had at least half moon shot or
crescent moon i don't know how that's
okay the full [ __ ] thing that makes
your eyes no i'm not i'm not a [ __ ]
werewolf dude yeah
i'm not gonna drink a full moonshine oh
they have that stuff will make you wake
up inside of your cousin dude that [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying you'll have a
family reunion and a uterus oh my god
you wake up with a [ __ ] four tires on
your body
you know
on bricks
good lord dog living in your butt dude
you're [ __ ] brick moranis
get me out of here what am i doing
that's not an air bag that's a [ __ ]
condom
filled with [ __ ] jizz
good god
no thank you
dude speaking of um
oh whatever football though
isn't it weird with guaranteed money
like aaron chris cousin kirk
kirk cousins is guaranteed 80 [ __ ]
million dollars don't you think that's
weird
like why would you even want to do good
oh i think if you once you get that
money it's hard to want to do good
that's what i'm saying i think because
then all you want to do is stay alive
yeah like as long as i'm alive these
years then i'm safe i get the money yeah
i get the lunches and the dinners mm-hmm
yeah because otherwise you're just
you're like damn i you know
i didn't stay alive or i got hurt or
whatever you're not gonna risk at all
no you're not gonna do anything but
you're just not you know if you throw
any interception you're like uh well
that happened yeah she should lose money
for interceptions
should lose money should lose a million
dollars you throw an interception are
you gonna throw a [ __ ] interception
after that
nope
you're not but you're not gonna throw a
pass out of that you're gonna call run
every single play yeah but that's fine
that's true if it's bad if you don't
have a running back and you just hand it
off and then just
throw it down what position and what
sport could you have honestly played man
and when you really look back at your
life
you know
and
what sport did you you think
legitimately in position you had a
chance to play
the closest
probably defensive lineman
yep
when i was
three
i was
top of my game really
yep
and then
downhill huh but yeah i could still
probably play for the vikings no i mean
i was a i was an athlete up until
everybody started growing oh 11. yeah so
like around i was like pretty solid at
baseball i played soccer tennis
um basketball
and then everybody started growing and
then i was [ __ ]
where's that weed out oh really
this is sports
yeah there was always a kid who like
didn't want to please like uh instead of
just
they didn't want to admit they didn't
want to play sports like oh so i have to
have something to do
to offset that you know so i'll do weed
you know right but you get to a point
when everybody starts growing
like in middle school then i was just
like oh i can't i thought that was great
i did but i was really late i was like
the runt of the litter you know what i
mean like uh charlotte's website tricky
yeah it was like charlotte's web dude
was it who was like was that the pig
yeah little randall or whatever his name
was what was he you bring a picture of
that thing was it rick santorum what was
his name i don't know
um
dude did you see the thing about wait
what sports did you play you were an
athlete weren't you you played
basketball oh you did i played
basketball yeah do you still play i was
good i could dunk at one time man which
is kind of crazy not not like really
good you could dunk a donut
oh yeah
and i turned into a werewolf
um you could dunk that i mean that's
like every guy's dream or girl sorry but
i mean that's like to dunk is like this
i can't even imagine that that's very
few girls dreams okay i know but i'm
just trying to be inclusive because i'm
[ __ ] a good guy man um did you see no
but no but duncan remember when they had
the hoops that you could adjust and like
bring down to like seven feet and then
every kill
you mean yeah basically yeah yeah
everybody was excited
somebody invented that the whites
hoop or whatever yeah
like they keep making more sports to try
and make sports for white people you
notice that
it's like look at this beach dunking or
whatever and it's like [ __ ] four and
a half foot goals you know do they
really oh yeah or it's like look at this
there i saw the other day there's like a
paddle ball it's like a
pickleball pickleball pokeball's hot
right now pickleball yeah pickleball's
fun as [ __ ] pickleball's funny [ __ ] but
it's definitely like hey
let's go over here and do something
white
before other people get over here and do
it better than us
i can see that i feel like it's a little
old it's old white i don't know like i
don't want to run that much it's like
lazy
oh i mean it's still really fun i like
pickleball but it's the people i play
with are young
are they really i mean yeah i've played
with 16 year olds where is this
um tennessee venice
tennessee venice
tennessee
um yeah i played in venice i mean yeah
anybody can play it i don't know yeah so
don't just say it's for old people what
i'm saying well i already did
so [ __ ] cancel me
i don't know what the [ __ ] going on
anymore but yeah i mean i don't know
it's a fun sport though
yeah it's fun um there's a sport i saw
the other day where they are there's uh
what's the thing where you hit the ball
around and it spins around the post it
was like a game cucumber ball no
um tetherball
there is team tether
ping pong now look it up that just
sounds like somebody was on asset and
made a sport well
i'm telling you this is the kind of
stuff that's going on nick
another
what is it team tether ping-pong can we
look it up dude what about extreme erect
chess have you played that
[ __ ]
naked erect you jump out of a plane and
you gotta [ __ ] play chess
that's huge right now in dubuque here we
go right here
team members these ufc guys and then
there's like handball ping pong is that
kind of what you're talking about right
here
no this isn't it this is what is that i
mean look just come out of the closet if
this is a thing i'll tell you about this
just play with a scrotum instead of a
ball yeah and then i'll take your
[ __ ] chest dude the gayest thing i
ever saw in my life right or rumored to
be gay was david spade eating what ha ha
i remember
there was um
i was at a hampton inn right oh i go
outside it was one of the when they'd
done the upgrades in like 2005
or seven which they were all late on
those upgrades those hotels yeah i
thought they did i
for me they seem to roll it out well
but i remember that um
i went and there was three men
in the hot tub playing frisbee together
and it was like they were this far from
each other oh my god
and it was just and i don't know if they
were gay men or not but it was like
i felt like it was like they were it was
like a little bermuda triangle where if
you got in there you're going down yeah
if you're going down yeah
yeah there's cause i mean to me that is
a like that's like a thing of saying hey
we're gay without saying we're gay right
like if you're throwing a frisbee in a
hot tub
right i mean you're not you can and it's
a little what's weird gay or straight or
anything it's a little weird were they
white people yeah yeah one of them
looked kind of hispanic or something
right something was you know had
happened to him
yeah
but that's yeah that's interesting
but that's um was it a [ __ ] ring
if they were just passing it around
and then playing horseshoes with their
boners you throw it like ring toss and
you gotta [ __ ]
land it so that would be gayer
than that
that's the other frisbee thing that's
true what about um what about us
um
oh what about the uh did you see the
thing what was the thing with the
bailout that just happened with the
uh you're talking about student loans
pretty much yes like uh did you get
student loans when you're growing up
no i went to barely graduate high school
really yeah i mean i should have gotten
a loan i think for college but i mean i
i just know of it my brother went to
college and he was [ __ ] by student
loans like forever
yeah i guess everybody is i don't really
know they got this bail they have so
they have his bailout program go up on
it and it wasn't christian what's going
on well it's basically just like the the
aftermath now of biden saying that he's
forgiving you know the student loans 10
grand for everyone it's like now
basically the question is becoming is it
legal and people are going to challenge
it in court because they're saying you
know hey if i paid off all my loans what
like what about me right any relief for
me
right so yeah do you think so because
that's where people are upset it's like
some people are like well
i sent my kid to college i saved money
to send him to college or her to college
and now i'm
i've paid that money off right and so if
someone didn't do that and they have
debt
and you're just
that's where it's becoming an issue
right i mean i can see that but it's
also those are different situations
though i mean some people might
be really there's got to be extenuating
circumstances and factors
of why they couldn't pay it off
oh yeah i think so but some people are
just saying like well do i get
do i get compensated for money
should there should be a legitimate
claim yeah that's what it seemed like
would be the solution to me is you also
offer but then how far back does that go
you know well that's the thing is that
brings up a bigger picture you know
everybody can be upset about
stuff like that i mean some guys a
hundred
and like i was the first guy at yale
yeah and i paid off my
ten dollar fee
i want 10 grand
yeah some guy's like i was a slave and
they're like you're white buddy is like
oh
[ __ ]
my bad
yeah i mean i don't know i don't know
how to solve that i think just don't go
to college
i don't know start a youtube channel i
don't know
whatever it's a new world now but i mean
yeah i mean i can see that because
student loans i don't even know i don't
even know if my brother's paid it off
he's a [ __ ] idiot yeah i pay i mean
it took me probably i mean i just paid
mine off i think about two years ago
but it's a long deal for people so i
could understand people wanting to but
then at a certain point you're like
where does it end it's tough it's like
like i think of it like someday there's
going to be a thing where it's like
there's going to be a pill where it's
like you can live forever right
but they're right
okay say there's a pill one day you can
live forever
okay but they're gonna say
they're gonna say hey
it's for only 40 and under because
whoever's the ruler at that point
they're like we don't really need these
old heads you know like you stop at a
certain age you can't buy it after 60.
right and it's just gonna be that cutoff
where it's like oh [ __ ] you know like
sometimes you just have to
there just has to be the thing where
it's like oh they get this break and i
you know
but we don't think about it like that
nobody wants to think like oh i'm happy
that these people get their debt reduced
i paid mine you know nobody thinks like
people are usually think oh well they
got they get this i should also get this
right which makes sense
um it's just we don't really think the
other way very often well no and nobody
really wants to be happy for anybody
else yeah
but it's i'm like that but if i'm at the
bar i'm like why do i have to pay my bar
tab right why can't they pay for it
because i've spent a lot of money here
and maybe i should get compensated
yep that's what i think
about all the money i spent drinking
deciding not to go to college yeah all
the money i could have saved and did
save
do you regret not going to college no
[ __ ] no yeah [ __ ] that
i mean you know it seems cool what would
you have been you think carpenter or
something like uh
i would go into carpentry college i
would have gone to harvard and majored
in carpentry
with a minor
and um pf trains damn right
that's possible
dude i could see you being a chef
somewhere you ever consider i would want
to be a chef i would also like
this was this is truly my backup plan i
want to be a teacher oh wow cause i just
thought that would be cool and it's
similar to stand-up where like you have
an audience but you also can like help
them like do the right thing and be good
people you know i mean that would that
was my thing is i just thought that
would be fun you get summers off and
[ __ ] what grade would you teach you
think i couldn't [ __ ] do anything
smart
six or under no i mean i'm no fourth i'm
not a blob of clay well i'm just [ __ ]
god dude seven gets kind of hard
i don't know like nine maybe eight where
they're like going i don't know
nothing like i couldn't [ __ ] teach
like trigonometry or some [ __ ]
or um pickleball but dude nine
everybody's got [ __ ] in their bag and
everything at school if what
nine is shady dude every dude that's
coming to your class stayed up all night
freaking
spanking it in his bed did you go to
school at alcatraz what the [ __ ]
oh my god i went to human high school
dude where you went you went to grade
school on epstein island i'm just
telling you
she's people's i didn't see it like that
i just thought fun i just thought when i
was happiest dude i grew up in the damn
skeet belt bro just telling you no [ __ ]
ninth grade is a real skeeter's team
[ __ ] tossing miracle whip in people's
faces like a [ __ ]
silence of the lambs person
[Laughter]
that's a scot geeter's dude ninth grade
you were just making sk i mean what else
were you doing no i said nine age nine
not ninth grade
ninth grade oh no what the [ __ ] no i
said
nine years old like third grade oh dude
oh not grade nine no
thank god
this got pretty sick
yeah no if not at all no like fun happy
children guide them to [ __ ] be happy
have a nice life i don't know i just
thought it would be fun to be a teacher
okay because it's like doing stand-up
you got like a crowd you can have fun
you get like i always like the cool
teachers
and like the cool school bus drivers and
the cool you know what i mean i just
thought that was fun and cool
what about spankings they just did you
ever get spanked before dude yeah my dad
used to [ __ ] beat me really not like
full on but like he would take a wooden
spoon and [ __ ]
and like you learn from that i don't
know
dude they had uh they just got in
missouri do you see this the missouri
school district reinstates spanking
[Music]
as punishment where's that at zach
it's uh
school district um catsville cassville
catsville that sounds like a lot of
rules don't apply there a lot of things
are coming back in catsville i don't
think it's just spanking
i think there's some witchcraft can you
zoom in on a little bit so i can see a
little bit more of it man it's a town of
four thousand just uh just outside of
springfield near the arkansas border but
yeah so they i guess basically they
realized that they was it was within the
code that they could do it so i guess
the teacher started doing it and no one
said anything they realized it was it
within the code yeah man we thank god i
want to read the catskill code
i'm sure there's a lot of [ __ ] topics
on there let me go go back zach
so that's go back please
but it is something that has happened on
my uh their code they also have like if
you if you get caught dancing you can
get hit with a rock
like i'm sure they have other [ __ ] so it
says down here it's allowed parents were
recently notified of the policy in june
and it's allowed only as a last resort
and with written permission from parents
this parent has to prove that the
teacher okay all right at least there's
some yeah i just hope albert pujols
isn't your freaking teacher that's the
thing
i remember did you ever get spanked
not in school really no
did you at alcatraz yeah i spanked two
times man whipped your [ __ ] nut sack
oh dude we had one man this man spangy
what was his name spanky no this man
named lawton mckee bring up a picture of
lawton mckee
where the hell are you going to find a
picture of lawton mckee
huh
is kind of a cool name though the web
lawton oh so he's it's spelled like law
law
yeah
oh i thought it was like l-a-u-g-h-t-o-n
okay what did he do see if you can see a
picture of him i can't see [ __ ]
i don't know he's the second row over
there to white guy far to the right not
right there yeah
what's the deal with this guy
this dude used to spank us man
that guy he's on the internet
why
look at my stupid why he's a [ __ ]
legend dude that guy spanked you oh that
guy beat me to he really beat me into
freaking decency oh my gosh and they
would also
uh
if he was bad they spank you and he had
one tooth that was rotten in his mouth
looked like a dog that guy looks like
this look like a headlamp like ken's
boyfriend from barbie oh this oh dude
let me zoom in on him a little
oh that's not even him dude
yeah that guy's never spanked anybody
that guy does own a leather swing set go
over the top left those people hugging
that's him what is that he had that one
yeah he had one large yellow grill piece
in the front looked like one of those
miner's lights on one of those kids that
got trapped you know
he just had a candy corn smile he had
that [ __ ] he had that
smile lamp baby you know what i'm saying
yeah the smile lamp he could trick or
treat year round bro he really had that
built in you know he could go into the
depths of the earth and trick or treat
yeah he could haunt octopus
oh god middle earth and try to find
doorbells yeah he had that little glow
baby inside of his grill
he had a glow worm
he had a glowworm grill yeah
good gosh yeah no i never but he would
spank us man and he would get what he
would spank you
and he would even why are you looking at
your penis because i'm just trying to
remember what he would do he would
you know he would have you hold on to
the desk like that and he would spank
your butt with that
and then they had another man named bill
brady that used to spank me over at a
different school
other schools joined in on hurting you
oh they all let you spank that when i
was a child man let you get spanked
they'll just hand you off oh you wasn't
you were that school if you were bad you
got freaking spanked
that's back when there's a little bit of
trust in the system you know okay
so that's what this place is saying that
they're going to go back to that as long
as the parents give permission they give
permission
they're all going to sign off on that by
the way oh they'll be like yeah
heartbeat and then that'd be great if
they had like a meter of how hard you
can do it like a spice level yeah give
them at a restaurant yeah yeah give them
a bomb
and give them a debunk
give them a [ __ ] splatter cory's
[Laughter]
do you know why free trials renew
without your consent
it's a business scam out to get you
that's right
don't let greedy corporations pocket
your money download rocket money to take
control of your subscriptions
rocket money they help you manage and
cancel subscriptions you don't need want
or simply forgot about with just one tap
you've heard me talk about my favorite
app true bill before
well true bill is now backed
by rocket companies and just changed
their name to rocket money
bottom line rocket money is everything i
loved about true bill but with a fresh
new look and feel
they are saving their members an average
of seven hundred dollars a year
start cancelling your unused
subscriptions and save money at
rocketmoney.com
theo that's rocketmoney.com
theo or download the app from the apple
app store or google play store
yeah did you ever get hit with a switch
that was one thing i never
we never did that that's like very
witchcraft huh i don't know but that was
one thing i remember adrian peterson
running back
um got busted um
switching his kid that ruined it for you
guys he hit his jenny's or something oh
really yeah it was like bad but i guess
he was like that's how but i'd heard of
a switch but i never experienced it and
black kid probably big jenny's easy to
accidentally hit that's a valid point
yeah point healthy jenny when you're
swinging at triple the jenny's on a kid
what do you you know it's not it's you
know
yeah you don't hay maker janie's dude
that's not what we do
what's the um
when did you lose your virginity man
[ __ ]
15 really yeah
it was pretty it was yeah
was it cool or not it was all right it
was kind of confusing but exciting but
also it was like it was on a church
retreat were y'all indoors or outdoors
it was outdoors yeah yeah
what about you
um
mom was outdoors as well
um
[Music]
17. you know
it's a solid age and uh
it was outdoors behind a bowling alley
actually that just got um
cordon cordoned off or whatever it's
called
cordon blue
they stuffed it with bacon you think no
they um just shut it down the bowling
alley or your penis the bowling alley
okay god shut my penis down years ago
dude you're filming [ __ ] small
lebowski i'm filming smallville over
there
[Laughter]
good girl um on a church retreat that's
crazy dude we were [ __ ] i mean i ugh
we were just shitty kids really what was
oh my god we were doing drugs and we
were going church retreats and was god
out there or not god was not present
he was he peaced out on our trips we
were stealing everything where were you
[ __ ] minnesota we were going to
stealing cheese from each other we would
stop yeah we would take our cheesebutt
plugs
no we would pull uh uh like stop at a
store and we would [ __ ] just just
loot
i mean just covert
but yeah but we were high as [ __ ] i mean
we were just
crazy yeah it was terrible and why why
was the church driving you all around
and i don't know we were going on like a
retreat to whatever we were supposed to
do i don't remember yeah
yeah it was pretty
yeah we went rogue but i mean you know
[ __ ] when you're a teenager you just you
just there's no rules you're just
[ __ ] bonkers i remember i caught
stealing i stole to impress this girl
one time
this girl showed up with tits and we'd
never seen them right you know we're
like jesus you know we were looking on
maps what is it you know she had damn
tits on her brother how big were they oh
big as you i mean you couldn't even see
them all at once you had to kind of back
up and get your buddy to look at the
same good god baby that was big
so what you guys were in the circus they
were big now i was at ymca
okay summer camp
and mr brad would come out there and he
was losing his hair and he'd come out
there
and make us do like tr like little
tricks in the pool and [ __ ] bro i think
he was probably something's wrong with
him yeah
but uh anyway this girl came her name
was bridget i think
and i think she actually died a couple
years ago and i hate to say that but i
do i do believe that
and uh you believe it or it did happen
it happened i don't want to say i just
don't want to say her life i don't want
people going looking at her and
commenting on her thing or whatever
they're dead boobs yeah yeah dude i mean
bro they had to have a casket with two
easter baskets off to the side of it
baby oh my god she had them [ __ ]
lurkers baby you know they just started
turning to the blob and like trying to
get off of her body oh bro
i'm on the porch i'm gonna ring them
more bells baby you know what i'm saying
she had anything like that she had them
freaking big speakers and 22s on her
baby those are those are the first
cowbells oh yeah she had those she's
utter damn she had some [ __ ] buff
utters couple buffets baby you know what
i'm saying you gotta open buff udders oh
[ __ ] strip club i'll just put one of
those nipples in my damn butthole
brother she really had those things yeah
um
what was that oh we got but we me and my
buddy got busted stealing some were
trying to impress her
what did you steal i stole this hat it
was like the dumbest head it was like
it was like a sock hat and you put it on
and it was just like this tall sock
coming off your head was it for her tits
it was just to be cool you know we sold
it from like a claire's boutique yeah
and i remember she saw us getting cuffed
me and this other kid oh you got full on
busted yeah
they cuffed you so you had to wait until
they called the cops
security could cough yeah did you point
at her tits and go this made me do it no
but i would have shot dude that would
have gotten you off for sure you're like
was anybody working with you you're like
yeah
there's two accomplices right there
punch and judy
she had them freaking
wow boy she had them freaking them
cowboys you know and moon balloons
oh
god damn
damn brother
man oh you got about is that still on
your record can you go to canada i can
go to canada i just don't think i can go
to like the mall in slidell louisiana
we used to camp out
that's open we'd be so excited to go to
the mall we'd go over there and camp out
we get a tent we go to the mall at the
day and we camp out at night
and then go again the next day
did you think there was going to be a
line to get in were you paranoid about
that no it was just far to get over
there and so it was like you know we
drove probably 18 miles to get over
there so we didn't want to
you know drive back and drive back right
so what would you do immediately when
the mall opened
like go in there just go in there and
just run around naked no just be by the
ac be by the fountain make wishes go to
the shoe shop go to the
you know poster store they had a big
poster store in there i remember i know
posters were big [ __ ] yeah i do what'd
you get
i was like obsessed with just
i'm such a sports freak so my whole wall
was athletes like steve setzler like old
minnesota vikings it would be vikings
and then some athletes i just thought
were cool like everybody had a bo
jackson poster you know what i mean he
was just he's [ __ ] bo jackson oh god
dude i had you know all those dudes
yui blab
you know what i mean could you be black
you think
could i be black like could you handle
it
i don't i don't know i don't i don't
know if i could handle it i um you
couldn't
probably not
but i did grow up i grew up in the inner
city so i was like hip to
rap music and all that [ __ ] and playing
hoop and [ __ ] and uh i remember i had
i was 12 years old 12 to 13
and i had a short dogs in the house
poster
um the album was one of my favorite
albums too short became a buddy of mine
and uh but i had that poster over my bed
and my mom was like oh look at that
they're dogs
that's fun it was all these dogs like
just [ __ ] chilling like oaktown
and but she just had no idea and then
there was another rapper named paris
and i had a poster of him and said the
devil made me do it bring him up paris
see what it is
but i thought it was bad i mean he's
black or white he was black but my mom
was like oh paris dude remember this was
before they had any mexican people
remember that
before i think they were had mexican
people but no no they didn't have a ton
you know i'm saying it used to be like
the way do you remember growing up there
wasn't a lot of mexican people around
like not in not in louisiana not in
minnesota
i mean yeah i mean not i mean seven
mexicans from your childhood
gary yeah there you go and gary is a
friend salvador i grew up with it okay
that's one guy dude and he's probably
from i'm not gonna i'm just gonna guess
el salvador
i never asked him about that i think i
just didn't want to know
yeah i'm not saying anything what i'm
just saying it's just interesting how
things have changed over time yeah i
know what you're saying but it was funny
see in paris did we see him yeah oh you
did i didn't get a good look i'm sorry
oh there he is huh but yeah posters are
the [ __ ] dude everyone like growing up
with posters it was a big deal posters
were so good remember when you got a
poster and you put it up did you put up
the pins in it you put the little yellow
tack stuff behind it and tack it
directly to the wall like a poor person
i did i think i don't know if we had
stickums back then that tape that had
was sticky on both sides oh we didn't
have that yeah 3m that was a one summer
where we were affluent yeah and then
and then it was [ __ ] ticked out
downhill yeah
it's funny cause i still did that
my place now i'm 45 years old and i got
i found this poster as a old james bond
poster vintage it was really cool and i
put up my living room
and i i hammered it in i didn't frame it
or anything and my roommate was like bro
what are you doing and i'm like putting
up this pit poster and he goes what are
you gonna frame
i'm just literally hammering it i'm like
still that
i just i don't know i know literally so
i still do this [ __ ] my buddy jason it's
open for me uh-huh
um and he goes we did the gig and i go
okay i'll send you a check
and he goes
what do you mean and i go i'll mail you
a check for the gig to pay you and he
goes there's venmo yeah and i'm like all
right right but i was still gonna like
go through like
finding an envelope
oh i remember there was something with
you one time i had to send you some
money you're like yeah just mail me a
check i'm like
yeah that's right how do i even
do that yeah it's so stupid uh yesterday
i remember looking for stamps
looking for stamps
what am i [ __ ]
opie from
andy griffith show dude i picked up a
pencil the other day and it blew my mind
right it blew i picked up a pencil
and i was like no
way it's like going back in time yeah
they're little time machines yeah dude
imagine when they had a feather with
[ __ ] ink that's how they signed half
of our
documents and our
history was just [ __ ]
and then
dip it in some
witch blood and then sign it
somebody's like oh look what i got you
for christmas a package of pens and it's
just like
oh do i eat this chicken now you're
right right with it yes and then [ __ ] it
yeah that's how they grew up
not wrong
sex dinner and then literacy
and then we draw a picture
of a butthole
yeah that's how people rolled dude did
you know that no two buttholes are the
same
i did not know that thank god
that'd be weird if i was like yeah no i
know
but in that isn't that really
interesting i don't know how to bring
that up brother
where was this huh
did you learn that from spade no man
it's the fingerprint of the gods baby
the b-hole son
how can they prove that that back jaw
why are we pulling up a picture of it
uh we're not doing a picture because
we'll get
fined or whatever who came to that um
conclusion i knew this but it's funny i
knew this yeah of course you did
can you just let's get some intel can
you click on something with some decent
information on it i'm trying to find
some uh some signs here
okay oh by the way back to hotels i
don't know we were talking about it
earlier
this is a true story about travels okay
and i remember one time i was going to
vegas
and i would go every fourth of july me
and my buddies and we would get
um fireworks so they're legal in nevada
so i was like
dude we're always paying a lot of money
to stay in vegas like get a nice room at
bellagio or something
and then i'm like dude what are we doing
why don't we stay at the travel lodge
it's like 50 bucks and we said we're not
even in the room we're in vegas
so they're like yeah
so we drive to vegas
get in the room check in where is how
far from the strip is it
it's not far 10 minutes maybe
so far and so
if that maybe five and then we get in
the room and um
my buddy goes to use the bathroom
and i put some my [ __ ] down and he goes
let's get the [ __ ] out of here man i'm
like what do you mean we just got here
and he goes nope tell everybody we're
leaving and i go we just got here bro
i'm tired
and he goes okay go in the bathroom
bathroom there's diarrhea on the wall oh
that on the wall
and was like a message or something no i
wish it was just confusing it was just
like splatter
but it wasn't like hey
bet um put all your money on red or
something that would have been a hot tip
yeah you know um the colts are gonna win
the super bowl diarrhea
no it was just diarrhea and then i was
like oh that's why you don't get a cheap
hotel room
you know wow i don't think all travel
lodges are like that yeah but that did
happen so hopefully they cleaned it
but i was
then we went to the bellagio and i spent
like a thousand dollars for the room
damn it would have been great if there
was diarrhea on the wall in that room
too
dude but with like a bunch of money
like against the wall with diarrhea and
you had to like yeah like
that would be cool though like take your
chances kind of yeah totally um
i'll tell you the craziest story that i
ever heard
jesus
this is a crazy story that ever heard
right so
that happened to somebody while touring
on comedy
so there was a man
right
and he was a comedian and he had another
man who was an opener the opener right
so after a show one night
uh
the headliner like this lady like um
this hot chick just bee lines up to him
right and it's like flirting with them
at the bar
in the lobby and blah blah blah she's
like all over him
she's like let's go back to my place and
hang out right
and he's like he felt like it was almost
like a little too like aggressive like
this almost feels weird right
so
uh she's like let's go back to my place
anyhow he's like no no you know um let's
just go back to my hotel it's not far
from here so they go to his hotel they
start making out in his hotel room and
she's like let's get out of here i got
some drugs and stuff back at my place
let's go
and
it was like 40 minutes away where her
place was
so he's like ah nah i'm not going to do
that it's already like 2 a.m or whatever
i'm not doing that
so he she like gets violent throws a
book at him in the hotel room like it
was a bible or phone book you know the
two books they have
so then uh he kicks her out of the room
when she's leaving she stops at the
opener's room right because she knew
where he was what room he was staying in
right
she gets the opener up they leave and go
out to her house right wherever it is
take a taxi out there
um
she and him start making out in some
room
she's like let me put some handcuffs on
you so she handcuffs him to the bed
they took some drugs or something that
they had at the house
she starts giving him a [ __ ]
and then she passes out right
so he's like chained to the bed trying
to wake this gal up you know this
[ __ ] and gal right
you know who's on you know break or
whatever you know he's trying to wake
her up
some headlights come across the window
right right and like go across the wall
like somebody pulled into the driveway
outside
so now the dude is like what the [ __ ]
bro like what is going on and here's a
door open
to the house so he's in there chained up
the girl's just like asleep in his lap
a guy an adult man walks by walks by the
front of walks by the room the room door
is open the hallway walks right by kind
of peeks in a little bit goes in the
kitchen starts making some food right
the dude's chained to this bed bro oh my
god he's got a half of a [ __ ]
he's still trying to wait the girl to
get a quick rest of her blow job or to
get out of there right
so uh the guy is sits in there he hears
the man sitting there watching
television and eating god
the dude comes back in a little while
later picks the girl up
takes her out of the room carries her
out of the room right then comes back
into the room
with the dude and said and asked him
what was going on right mm-hmm and uh
the kid tried to tell me you know i just
this is what happened this is what
happened
and um the guy
finished blowjobbing the dude
that's amazing
let him go right right and told him if
he ever came back on his property or
whatever he was gonna [ __ ] kill him
or if he ever caught him with his
daughter or something again he was going
to kill him right it's a happy story
so then anyway the kid gets to like us
uh uh
pay phone or whatever right and calls
back to the hotel
and um and the other convocate kicked
the girl out uh got an attacks or
whatever and came and got him
jesus that's the craziest story i ever
heard that's crazy that's pretty crazy
wait i gotta pee so bad you do go pee
somewhere yeah pee outside or pee in the
bathroom um yeah that's pretty insane so
there was a similar thing my manager
told me about his neighbor
and
they were like in their late 60s maybe
70. and him and his wife
the neighbor and uh her husband were
really kinky
and she got into like a leather swing
to get [ __ ] or whatever and he had a
heart attack while she was in the swing
and she couldn't get out he had her neck
and then she started screaming
and then my manager at the time he went
over to the herder and went in and saw
her in the sling and they had text and i
go did you [ __ ] and he was like
no
i'm like [ __ ] and he goes no i had
to revive the guy and he didn't die but
um i'm like he [ __ ] her but i just
thought that was funny too just she was
she was just sitting there like [ __ ]
brian cowan you know i mean just waiting
to get drilled by [ __ ] shop just
sitting there
[ __ ] shop thief or sutherland
yeah yeah that's what i call him dang
no kidding there was a bit about job
like i guess he said people say he stole
some fajita joke from me did he don't
know i don't care it was just funny i i
know brennan i don't care if he did but
i doubt it i mean he's had fajitas
yeah a lot of people have had fajitas
yeah
but i haven't seen i don't know if i've
even seen i i haven't seen that joke it
doesn't come to mind no i mean who
[ __ ] cares but no but that it is
getting funny like so watch out when you
get in your leather swing
yeah don't [ __ ] yell for help man
just die
i remember one night some girl wanted to
have sex and we were so high on cocaine
i just laid there like a [ __ ] owl
and it was just just spinning your head
around
just
yeah
yeah i can't dude cocaine sucks
i remember every time i would do it
panic attack yeah because i like going
to sleep i like passing out i don't want
to [ __ ] be up more well if you need a
[ __ ] zip to go like a couple more
hours drinking
i guess
but well i remember i realized why i
liked cocaine was because or why i like
it i mean you know i'll always love it
you know it'll always be my second or
fourth or third love yeah but
i'm dangerous but okay
because it's faster than beer i don't
like dr i don't want to like it's faster
than ever around about how i feel you
know
it's like when people are like hey man
we should drive to uh
to um saturn yeah like i'm gonna fly
yeah i'll see you there you know what
i'm saying
but it's like i want the thing i wanna
whatever the feeling i want i want it
now
i don't wanna sk you know i don't wanna
meander around the lit you know it's too
risky out there just mailing around
having a beer
yeah i once yeah
yeah you want to just get there i want
the police in my [ __ ] nut sack
immediately oh wow all right you know
but yeah you want to
it's like a flight you want to get there
yeah i want to get you you want a half
hour flight you don't want six hours you
want to [ __ ] be
yeah you want to [ __ ] build a stadium
or something yeah that's why i realized
i like because it was just like it was
just faster more effective that's uh
everything else about i hated panic
attacks you know be you know
not being able to look at people you
know [ __ ] um
sweating driving and doing cocaine in
your car when you were young right you
know all that kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
some dude tried to trap me in a bathroom
one time
and was i think trying to be sexy or
something and i remember that i would
think so you know i would think that
would be his motive but it was like drug
induced you know because there's a lot
of drug-induced homosexuality that
happens you know people get high
and then they
they get there's more tendency for gay
they go dick diving yeah don't they yep
i mean it seems like it's more of a
popular thing in the world or you can at
least blame it on that
you know what i mean
so you can be like dude i drank a gallon
of molly and [ __ ] your whole
um university at that party
yeah yeah
professors everything the mascot
nobody was safe from
my [ __ ] bone
do you um
yes what was the story you were telling
me that you were gonna tell me about the
craziest drunk story did you tell me it
that was the one about the leather swing
set oh yeah or with the leather sling or
whatever it is
i mean it's not up there with um [ __ ]
ring frisbee hot tub
well that is so funny
it's so weird
good god but yeah i mean anyway i'm
excited to go on tour and experience
yeah so tell me about some of the tours
so are you gonna be sober on the whole
tour no
i don't know i'm gonna try i'll probably
cave a couple there's certain cities
that are
you know when you look at a tour and
you're like oh
this town is gonna be tricky
to like if i i mean
to not drink in chicago is hard but i'm
only there for one day so that helps but
uh to not drink in like
nashville that's gonna be tricky
there's there's certain cities where san
diego
tricky vegas obviously
but that's a lot and how many cities are
you going to i'm doing like 30 right now
okay nickswortson.net for tickets are
you touring this year anymore or no yeah
got some shows coming up um
where are you going san diego
denver
somewhere else denver's great altitude
though god damn dude i get [ __ ] on the
altitude every time if you're going to a
place with altitude
drink water like i know it sounds like
stupid or whatever drink a lot of water
before you go and when you're there yeah
because it's i got i just did six shows
in denver they're amazing i love denver
but dude i got sick as [ __ ] i was
throwing up in the green room
every day before the dream to it yeah um
yeah the only reason i asked you about
the drinking stuff is just because i'm
always curious about that kind of stuff
i'm curious about like you know the
effect it has on people how do people
manage it because our lifestyles are
also different lifestyles you know way
different
it's different than a normal lifestyle
you know like we usually get into this
business because like you know we have
different um
ways that we
uh feel okay in the world and you know
there's a lot of people in our industry
that like you know battle with
substances and stuff it's very normal
yeah total indians it's very normal i
just want you to know why i ask about
that kind of stuff yeah of course no
it's a valid question and i've dealt
with so much [ __ ] in the past like i
said you know i almost died yeah and i
didn't know this for people that don't
know i almost died i was in the hospital
in denver
and i was there for three and a half
weeks
and there's people that have quadruple
bypass surgeries that are in and out in
four days
and i was over three and a half weeks
and the doctor told me i had a 10 chance
of living
and then when i got out and i got better
they had lied to me i was supposed to be
dead so my family flew in to say goodbye
to me no and they told me that you have
a 10 chance and then my sister was like
yeah they lied that you were gonna you
were supposed to die
so that's a trip dude when you
experience something like that and then
you come back to life essentially
it just changes your whole
[ __ ] ste
mindset because you're just like oh i'm
like now living on borrowed time that's
how i see it so how long once that hap
because what you got taken were you at a
place and collapsed did something like
what was what happened i flew into
denver i got sick in my hotel
minneapolis
and then i was like whatever i'm used to
that i was throwing up like bile then i
got on the plane drank on the plane
threw up into my carry-on
so then i got off the plane i'm like
[ __ ]
so then i hadn't eaten or anything so i
ate like you've been were you drinking
i just kept drinking but i kept vomiting
and it was more and more painful than i
had
a pain in my but i had a pain that was
different it was like pain like fire
pain yeah and i kept trying to drink
through it
and then i'm like oh this no something's
horribly wrong
and i went
to the medic at the airport and they're
like oh you need an ambulance at the
airport well yeah they have like
somebody you know what i mean i'm like
hey something's wrong wait was it that
express spa or whatever that uh
it wasn't like a massage chair i didn't
sit there and like
no i
grabbed a human
okay at a ticket counter i'm like hey i
something's wrong and the guy looked at
me and he goes oh you need an ambulance
they call me an ambulance and i went to
the [ __ ] you got ambulance out of the
airport
yeah where does it pick up at departures
or arrivals i don't remember but i think
i i think it was departures because they
thought i was going to heaven
yeah
jesus was my pilot he was like
and did you have a beer at the airport
i was drinking vodka and i just kept
going and throwing it up and i'm like
okay this is i can't get through this i
drank a gatorade threw it up i had a
like a banana
or something you were puking up bile
what's after bile
um
more bile
and then blood yeah and then blood so
then then it was blood at the hospital
it was [ __ ] gnarly dude
it was like it was
i'll never forget then i i don't even
remember a whole week they were telling
me about what i was doing
and the nurse was like yeah you're like
throwing haymakers trying to like
you're watching wrestling on your
computer
yeah it was crazy but there's pictures
of it there's pictures of me with like
they had to like put mittens on my hands
you wouldn't drink yeah no so i wouldn't
pull the ivs out and really yeah it was
[ __ ] bonkers so you were you went i
mean you went crazy yeah essentially
like i totally lost my [ __ ] yeah and the
altitude was a big factor in that what
[ __ ] no it wasn't
like you tell these crazy stories you're
like i drank 70 drinks i [ __ ] yeah
you're like but there were some raiders
fans there and that's kind of the thing
that made things strange man yeah no i
drank a gallon of house paint but you
know
there was a drizzle
there was a drizzle outside yeah it was
yeah it was a cloud it was cloudy but
yeah i didn't plan on like that
happening so but do you think you could
because you could if you because you
probably i mean at that point you get
cirrhosis bad things happen to your body
yeah i mean i came really close but i
didn't i mean i'm fine now i mean
obviously like
did they say you can drink again or you
can't drink again
well it was the doctor goes if you have
another drink you're gonna die so i was
like well that doesn't make sense
but i'm like okay so then i i rehabbed
and then got you know better and i got
really healthy
and then i went and got a checkup three
months after and the doctor was like oh
yeah a different doctor back in la and
he's like yeah you're fine everything's
fine and i'm like what and he goes yeah
it's all yeah everything's back your
liver's back i mean i was like really
you're living
hard well your liver can
rebound yeah i mean you can get to a
point where it can't where i've had a
handful of friends where that's happened
to
but i mean you can push it and then
you've got to really dry out so i did it
with vitamins and [ __ ] milk thistle
everything just built back up
and then i still wait another six months
and then covet hit and quarantine i went
to key west
and i'm like you know what i'm just
gonna it doesn't make sense so i had a
cocktail and i was i was fine and then i
drank again
yeah i just want you to be which sounds
dumb i'm sure people like you you're a
[ __ ] idiot but i didn't drink like i
was drinking very rogue i mean i was
just boom shots and just completely
stupid wow but now i'll like you know i
can have a cocktail i can do stuff like
that but you do have to be
really careful do you think you can have
a cocktail yeah i did i told you i had
like a cocktail when i wrapped this
movie buddy games part two hard r
yeah so we celebrated i had a cocktail
and it was fine
so yeah it is interesting you know with
the levels of you know what people can
do because some people can't they have
one drink and then they wake up in a
[ __ ] prison and i know but that's
most your stories sound like that you
know i know
but i don't know somehow i've made it
knocked out
oh you're [ __ ] yeah i mean you're
you're like
yeah you're like the ghost of
fuddrucker's past
i am dude you keep going the ghost of
future chili's
what chain restaurant
is the one that's time to [ __ ] shut
it down dude
i don't know i haven't eaten anywhere in
a while long john silvers
didn't they peace out for a while and
then they kind of made a mini comeback
and then people were like no i still
have blood in my stomach i think they're
still out there yeah they think they
merge with boot barn or something
something crazy
i don't know i mean in some places
i don't know what to say cause i don't
want to get
they're good
i don't see a partnership but yeah i'd
love to see lds versus ljs bro
long john silvers versus long latter-day
saints oh the church of latter-day
saints yeah
that would be a battle
that would be that would be a battle
i'd love to see more battles like that
you know things were getting weird out
there they had um
what was the thing with the uh
the drivers they were the
oh yeah the kia boys this is crazy
okay so um
thefts of kias and hyundai's are soaring
like 800 percent because there's a tick
tock trend and there are no videos of it
obviously but there is a tick tock trend
where you can basically hotwire a kia
with just like touching the usb port or
touching it with like an aux cable for
your car you know and then kids are
sharing how to do it with the hashtag
kia boyz so it's just like
i mean everyone with kia or hyundai you
gotta lock yourself up right now it's
happening god
yeah my friend got a kia stolen that's
funny not funny but like oh you can jump
start with an earring dude
what yeah it's like a huge design flaw
you just make contact with something and
they're here i'll show there's screen
grabs oh that's a nightmare
there's screen grabs of it here because
they delay disabled the videos but you
just touch something in there and then
it it goes and they haven't fixed it yet
it's unbelievable oh that's brutal if
you're out there don't [ __ ] do that
good god why like you know why make
people's lives worse
stealing somebody's [ __ ] car they
probably have a family and if you know
what i mean
dude kia sofia is also a black girl that
i would kia sophia behind was a black
girl that i went to school with is that
true yeah so they should easily pay her
for this right yeah they've got they own
money now
yeah that's crazy i also don't i don't
know i've never owned a kia
you ever borrow your parent's car
without them knowing i've stolen my
parents car yeah
i crashed my dad's car i've crashed my
parents cars why what happened
um
i got drunk and went to buy drugs
i got drunk and went to buy drugs that
night when i was in high school now what
kind of drug you're talking about weed
weed yeah yeah then when going for weed
was like we're getting some [ __ ]
weeds oh it's so exciting man yeah my
friend chris i would knock on his window
late at night
and he'd be like want something dude
and he would give me like 20 bucks worth
ah i remember i was
loved weed so much i sold my dad's penny
collection
i went and cashed in
booklets yeah those books all the
midwestern things that your parents had
yeah that's not even enough to buy wheat
i think i bought like a half of a seed
bring those up
bring up the penny collector books my
grandmother had these oh there they are
yes when i was a kid he had a ton of
them too with the with an indian head or
whatever yeah oh
i think the rare ones i was able to cash
in for more money i doubt that i doubt
it
oh so sad but that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] i
know we've all done it kid like don't be
an [ __ ] i was like i think back oh my
god this one's worth 895 bucks right
here this one
we've all done this nick
and what'd you do you borrowed the car
and what i would drive to go by the weed
and then but my dad's like one of my
moms i got too high and then went off a
ditch
and then my dad's eyes turned into a
telephone pole because you know in the
midwest it's like there's um ice
when it snows after it snows and then uh
yeah i hit an ice patch win
and then into a telephone pole yeah and
these guys were chasing me i think they
were like kind of thug dudes oh yeah and
i thought they were gonna kill me and i
crashed my car and then they pulled over
and they're like are you all right and
i'm like
no it's my dad's car i'm going to
[ __ ] die and they're like all right
let's drove away
yeah
like we stopped to help but yeah no they
were like we're gonna [ __ ] this dude up
and then we're like oh now his dad's
gonna [ __ ] him up way worse yeah
the [ __ ] father fury
just jenny's
this haymaker to the jan jan it's crazy
now how with that car theft people could
when a burglar learns something they can
now put that out it's like here's a way
where you can
it's like why would you pay it forward
right but
i understand you wouldn't it's weird
it's dumb it's not helpful to society
but this is the kind of thing that
people are just thinking like this is
how you can do it you know this is how
you can
steal a car you know yeah it's crazy are
you on tick tock yeah
what do you do we're on there we just
share stuff experiences and moments from
the show
okay um
but they had another it's just it's just
interesting how there's like this
vigilante
there's like vigilante um
social media for like if you're doing
something bad or something good they had
another story with bring up the story
with the lady that followed you know
what i'm talking about zach yeah yeah
yeah
um this was on reddit this got a
ton of views but basically this business
owner
she was robbed and found the person who
did it and found him on the bus and
followed them home
um this video is one minute long so just
give it a like yeah business owner
follows thief on the bus follow her home
confronts her ass
so
so what did she steal watch this she
left and got on the bus which my
employee notified me about
so i drove to meet the bus guys okay so
this raggedy-ass [ __ ] just came into
erotic
and stole from my store
from my store okay stop don't touch me
and we're gonna follow her to her house
because she said she's gonna pay for it
there
right
yes
okay
so enjoy the ride and we'll let you know
where she lives
let's play a game called look in the
thief's purse so let's see what she has
stop oh she also took a skirt justin did
you see that
yeah that's the girl right there
she's still closed
you're looking at me like i'm crazy and
you stole from me the irish imagine the
shock on a thief's face and they got it
don't steal from small businesses okie
okay it's chinese oh okay but wow is
that unbelievable that's incredible good
lord
that's what it's just it's interesting
that like
we're becoming our own police it's like
the police there are almost like the
secondary part of
the policing it's like well yeah it's
just people taking into their own hands
and using social media to call people
out
and go like [ __ ] this yeah but it's like
that forever it's like just this there's
like this um it's like that for
everything it's like that on both sides
it's like that on if you're the criminal
or if you're the victim
you know it's just interesting how
there's like social media provides this
vigilante sort of uh
comeuppance yes come up and access what
word am i thinking of zach am i making
any sense
come on puns i mean justice we're
talking about you know right it's
justice and injustice but it's either
way it's like well that's a catch-22 of
social media and that's like the extreme
dichotomy of how it's like it can be the
best tool ever or it can be a very
negative tool yeah you know what i'm
saying
we'll be right back with more from
something episodes
but yeah um white oprah's dude um white
oprah's would be the best band name
that'd be a sweet um trilogy movie the
black steadman's mm-hmm
um what else anything else in the news
zak i just wanted to see if there was
anything else we wanted to chat about
i'm excited for your tour you're going
to 30 cities you look honestly better
than i see you look great they hung out
last night man you're i just feel like
your energy's good you just i'm just
happy for you you know thanks man no
it's great and it's like it's fun
i got everything out of my system i mean
the thing about covid is that i just
kind of evaluated my life and like i'm
like
45 years old i'm where am i gonna what's
my next chapter you know what i mean i'm
like i've already
done
a lot you know yeah but i want to just
do something where
i don't know i just came to terms with a
lot of [ __ ] and a lot of baggage and why
i was drinking so much and like why you
know so i drank in key west and then
just came back full throttle
where i was like okay i came well i went
home and i'm i looked around my place
and i'm like why do i have all these
shoes why do i have these clothes i sold
my rolex i sold my diamond chains i sold
everything i sold half my shirts almost
all my shoes i'm like this is just
like just minimalized my life where i'm
just like i just want to you don't need
that much so i gave it away i didn't you
know i just was like here
you know i have this
i gave it to you know groups of you know
goodwill type places rolex you gave to
him you sold it [ __ ] no i sold that yeah
sold that we probably didn't pay that i
bought a tailgail
no i didn't but yeah i just sold all
that stuff so i'm like what do i do so
now i just i only i've got a couple
viking shirts and then i have a fur coat
and a speedo yeah because i feel like
those can do both weathers yeah
did you um
did you see aaron rodgers on
um no what did he do
i was just interested
he told they talked about uh
what did he say
they talked about kind of if we i can't
wait to just feel the fury of football
season
my first show is uh pittsburgh opening
day
i'm excited in september your first show
is on opening day of football yeah on a
sunday which i'm so stoked because i've
only been to pittsburgh a couple times
or sunday sunday so i'm fired up about
that it's going to be [ __ ] bonkers
it's such a great football town i love
good football town shinley park dude yes
shinley park the frickin downtown i love
pittsburgh dude yeah what is the
sandwich place primonee brothers oh
primanti brothers yeah they got all kind
of good stuff over there it gets a good
great place thick lady out i saw a thick
chick one time
catching a bus having a gerry olshansky
jersey bring up gerry olshansky bring
him up
this is the kind of woman you want over
there i go to pramani brothers last time
i was there and i was like hey can i
hold the cheese and i had them hold like
a bunch of stuff on it and they looked
at me they were excited that i was there
and then they were like disappointed
that i so i'm allergic i can't have jet
dairy you said jerry o'shansky
yeah olshansky ol what's isn't dairy is
his name it's dairy or jerry i'm
allergic to dairy i just said that
this is going to be for the stillers
well no that's jerry stiller pittsburgh
steelers
is that old shansky right there
old jerseys are always great too huh
jerry olsovsky yeah there you go
linebacker they pronounce it different
that's polish
yeah beautiful
um yeah so i'm excited i'm excited for
football it's just it's weird when
there's no football
yeah
but you're a saints fan well yeah you
know i've they've played some story
games over the years yeah we've had
great the miracles happened
yeah
and then we then the next season we won
with kyle rudolph in the end zone
we got that last minute uh last second
catch
i don't know if i remember that one yeah
that was a year i think it was a year
after
and then we still don't have a [ __ ]
super bowl god damn it
what are the saints that they have one
or two we have one you don't have one
yet no
you don't have a super bowl yet you guys
won against brett favre when you get the
bounty gate [ __ ] i think you guys won
that year but all of that all you guys
have been there since the beginning
weren't you in like in the second super
bowl we were in four super bowls in a
row
we lost all you lost all of them yeah we
don't have a super bowl it's insane
it's awful
the bills just lost their punter you see
that guy he got accused of rape
yeah i saw that it's crazy
yeah it's crazy dude the bills i mean
like there's teams that i root for i
mean i i if the bills want to be happy
you know oh yeah i really like the bills
they've gone through hell in high water
buffalo
yeah
heartbroken they had um that
the tight end dawson knocks his brother
passed away yeah that's awful
did they figure out how he died i don't
know
yeah that's terrible
i don't know if they did i i think he
did it said that he died in his sleep
yeah man that just broke my heart yeah
that's terrible and then you have to go
out and play i know what's this guy when
you see those games where they're like
yes mom just died last night he's got a
pitch or something yeah you're like oh
my god did you see the manti teo
documentary no i think you're the one
that told me about it yeah it was like
the catfish documentary it's unbut it's
i want to see it because i remember when
it happened well yeah they had this so
there's yeah there's a
a guy he grew up playing football
and there's a guy who turns into a woman
[Music]
and she's the one who was pretending to
be
this
girlfriend the whole time
she
so it's a guy it's a trans or a
cross-dresser or trans didn't really go
into it okay
so the the person who was faking him
pretending to be a girl was actually a
guy
uh is that illegal turned into a girl
okay so the guy became a girl yeah
okay the guy became a girl and just
catfished him for a long time and he
just had really he seemed like he just
has kind of very simple christian
beliefs you're not simple but like you
know basic philosophies of faith and
like right um obviously some gullible
you know
but
[ __ ] i've been catfished before it's
very spooky
but i mean the story's unbelievable and
then they kind of like championed the
girl like she was like coming into her
own it's like it doesn't even like
they're like but it ruined this it like
didn't ruin it yeah well but it
definitely marred this guy's life
there's a documentary about it that the
guys now [ __ ] has to deal with he
dropped to the third round of the nfl
draft and he was a heisman candidate
remember yeah i remember that yeah i
know that i mean at the end they're like
showing the girl dancing it's like but
at least i you know it's like this is
how i learned to come into my own and
it's like what genital trickery yeah but
come on man
it's crazy that netflix like kind of
championed her like as if yeah i mean
come on that's not cool but then uh teo
said he you know he's he's you know he's
very much about forgiveness and
well right it was fascinating it was
just like man i'd have been
way more t.o that would have been
genital warfare yeah because they caught
that she pretended also then to be the
brother of the girl he was dating and or
communicating with
and then he's she's like she called as
her own brother
and said that the girl was
was dead
then called back a few weeks later and
said she's back yeah she's back what
so now he's into zombies or what is
going on what happened
bro the whole thing dude booby doo
oh it will be spooky oh
yeah that's weird i'll check it out have
you ever been catfished
by a catfish yeah yeah [ __ ]
but but you know
it was hot it was hot fish big mouth i
was like game on
it turned out it was a salmon oh i'm
like this [ __ ] salmon can't be
chooser dude exactly ma'am
samuel
um no i haven't i'm not very like
internet
um
i just think it's weird it's you know it
happens for some people but i don't know
i got catfished before man yeah of
course you did cause you grew up in a
[ __ ] swamp on alcatraz that's true
was it fried catfish or breaded oh it
was it was uh blackened
oh you know what i'm saying brother
yeah i think we all do um
did it go the distance or what did you
do no i ended up talking to the person
on the phone i was about to go into a
panera bread
and uh i stepped out and took the call
and it was a man it was a black male
and trying to pretend to be a woman
and i'd been texting with this gal for a
while and then it was like wow
you know
did you guys still hit it off
no i was nice for a little bit cause i
had a couple minutes to kill anyway i
don't even like panera and i had a
couple minutes to kill anyway and i was
like uh you go to panera bread a lot by
the way i don't like it people always
are like let's meet at panera and i'm
like it's bread dude yeah it's basically
like it's like a library for fat
you know it's like
i don't want to go in there
dude yeah like hey want this apple want
all this bread you want a cookie with
your bread want some bread with your
bread bread that's too much bread hey
you want this hat this bread hat and
your [ __ ] cousin's wearing a damn he
has a pita vest mate you know it's like
yeah it's stupid man i remember i got a
bread turtleneck there and i was like
why did i buy this just
i would just eat around the turtleneck
it was stupid dude my [ __ ] band
called bread i've never even heard him
my nephew hurt his back they put a
[ __ ] tight baguette around his neck
oh my god like jesus yeah my dad lost
his leg and they gave him a [ __ ]
whole baguette as a peg leg
and then birds you know just kept eating
his leg it was a nightmare dude we went
through hell the whole thing's insane
yeah no it's scary they need to stop i
don't know if we've covered everything
anything else you think we need to hit
zach any good news going on
we feel good we hit a lot of it the last
thing i was going to pull up and you
just mentioned this earlier about like
is it even worth going to college
anymore is there was a study that one in
four gen zers plan on being an
influencer wow oh my god and shockingly
enough in this study the men are think
they're more likely to be influencers
than the women and they're relying on it
more
but do you see where the uh well first
of all you have to understand there's
going to be less
because of automation there will
probably be less jobs in the future
right i was talking about this with joe
rogan that they have um
at one point it's going to come to the
fact that you're going to have like
everybody's going to have like a gig
economy or is going to be an influencer
you're going to have like two uber
drivers holding each other at gunpoint
to get the other person
to be their fare you know it's like
everybody's gonna be an uber driver or
everybody's gonna be an influence like
watch me right now you know subscribe to
my tits you know like get in my like
we're literally gonna be fighting to
have the other person be
the uh consumer
i mean we already are but if if if more
actual jobs go away
you're gonna have people holding
subscribe to my [ __ ] you know right
yeah subscribe
subscribe to my butthole that's
different than everybody else
[Applause]
but i mean how many things can you
influence i don't even it's such a broad
term it's like you're an influencer so
what is that you're just gonna have
billions of people just dancing and then
you know i don't understand well that's
a good point too and also being an
influencer people are just on social
media so i think that's all that this
means
right i mean zach in a in a way that's
kind of all they're say you know it's
like they could just be kind of saying
that
yeah i mean they're basically just
saying that like i guess when they're
looking at their future i think these
kids are realizing that they have to
grow up like monetizing themselves in
apps which is like kind of [ __ ] up but
yeah i mean um yeah we still need
[ __ ] doctors and lawyers like go to
school right [ __ ] i mean i just couldn't
do it because i didn't know the money or
the grades or the brain yeah but if you
if you're smart you know [ __ ] go to
college i'm not [ __ ] on college at
all i mean if you utilize it and it's
tricky for kids it always has been about
what do you want to do and you're 18
you're like i don't [ __ ] know dude
but i mean hopefully like you can find
hopefully college can if you're open to
it find you a path of like
you know finding something that you want
to do that can that college can
facilitate yeah i don't know
college is see it seems fun because i
love college sports watching hoop and
football and like you see the games
everybody's all fired up my buddy went
to my brother went to madison and he
watched madison like the house of pain
and they play and they all jump around
like that would be fun just to go to
college for that
oh yeah i think that's one of just only
to go to football games that's one of
the best experiences i think over the
years of uh traveling to do comedy is
sometimes being in a city or a town
where there's a good college game on
that next day and you stay an extra day
and you grow
and you
i remember you applied to cracker barrel
to go to college there but you did well
i applied to their technical institute
right you know it's where they make a
lot of tech it's where they make a lot
of the condiments yeah you know
but
um
but isn't that crazy though that that's
it's like i even noticed my little niece
the other day got a separate chain like
started her own like separate channel
and it's just like
well this is this is just what
it's part of life it's like you have to
have this other existence
that means almost more than your actual
existence
what do you mean like metaverse [ __ ] i
mean well your fight yeah like your your
your existence of
online your personality right yeah i
mean you can create a life or a life
that people see you they think you live
you know what i mean right but that's
it's like that's become
it feels like if that many people are
gonna think that they're gonna be
influencers if
then you're like
that's going to be a big part of
don't judge me as a person judge
whatever this idea of me is that i'm
presenting you know right but people
also thought like that people guys were
going to have hair like motley crue for
the rest of their lives good point so i
mean [ __ ] goes out we'll see
let's see we'll see what happens did we
cover a lot yeah we did bro i think we
did um nick schwartzen where can people
uh jokes from my face to her
make joke from face make joke from
facebook and then um yeah
nickswartson.net has all my dates
realnickswartson on instagram here we go
right here yeah dude look at that
beautiful and then it's bleeding in the
next year i'm adding more dates i'm at
mobile alabama which i love atlanta
um vegas i'm announcing and then working
on kansas city st louis some other
places man it's super fun man it's a fun
show i love this act i'm retiring a lot
of
stories and it's it's fun as [ __ ] man so
you seem really motivated yeah i'm fired
up man
yeah it's good good [ __ ] yeah so and
then i got three rated r comedies coming
out reno 911 christmas the binge 2 which
is based on the binge movie with vince
vaughn sequel and then buddy games 2
which is buddy games that we did
um that did great over quarantine so
and then i'm writing this movie with
goosen the director of grandma's boy and
then you're developing that movie with
david so we got some [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
pipeline dude
trying to stay busy trying to stay alive
nick schwartz and i love you man and i'm
happy for you and i'm glad that you seem
healthy and
um yeah i want to come see a show dude
come to a show anytime man yeah and
we'll [ __ ]
get a switch and just hammer each other
each other's genitals oh dude
on stage that's what i'm talking about
dude
only uh one of a kind b hole right here
you can't beat him nick swartzen thanks
bro yeah bud now i'm just floating on
the breeze and i feel i'm falling like
these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i
i can feel it
[Music]